[Music]
hello
did you hear about dali no not wall-e
dal-e no not a human painter the
transformer-based ai painter
twitter exploded again because open ai's
new image generation model called
dal-e was announced so here we are
trying to figure out how cool it is and
how this could happen
image generation was already spectacular
with dedicated models used for
rendering people there were also models
for rendering animals from textual input
but the difficulty was to generate these
kinds of images
from text when the text combines
concepts
and the image has to produce plausible
combinations of these concepts
so open ai looked down upon the world
decided to stop resting after publishing
the great
3 and quickly solve the problem of image
generation from text
2. yes just like that dal e was born
and open ai rested the next day oh
no they should not rest because they
still have a paper to write about doll e
and of course we do not have access to
the model so we only have openai's blog
posts to look at
but the situation is not new they did
the same with gpt3
perhaps again a multi-dollar company
will buy exclusive rights to the model
and we will never see it again
okay miss coffee bean we were cynical
enough
so here it is dull e creates images that
combine
unrelated concepts in plausible ways
check
it can also generate storefront text
i have never seen anything like this did
you
let us know in the comments if you did
dull e can do
also style transfer by a text prompt
so it can modify the style of an image
following a textual description of the
desired output
wow how crazy is this ok enough showing
off
what is this model and how can it work
dull e is i cite a 12 billion parameter
version of gpt
3 trained to generate images from
textual descriptions
oh that explains everything no
it does not gpt 3 looked at text
not at images what do images and text
have in common miss coffee bean has a
variety of videos
on this trying to explain that images
and text are not that different kinds of
input for a transformer that usually
works on sets as long as both images and
text are regarded somehow as sequences
or elements in a set
everything works again there have been
some kinds of
image sequentialization approaches in
the literature
but it is safe to assume that open ai
stuck to their approach from
image gpt where they sequentialize the
image row by row
into a 1d vector so now that we know how
images can be sequences
we are ready to know how dal e is
basically gpt3 also looking at images
dal e is also a language model that
receives both
text tokens and sequentialized images as
input
up to 1280 tokens
why is the sequence length limited to
this number
because attention scales quadratically
and increasing the input size can really
blow up computational time
then like in language modeling the goal
is to predict one token after the next
text tokens are words or sub words and
image tokens are image pixel values
this also means that dal e does not only
generate images from text but can
also continue images if the beginning of
the image is already
in the prompt following the text so that
was it for the technical details okay
but why does it work why did the image
generation problems need a specific
gun or vae architecture to solve the
problem only partially and now
a transformer based model can do it all
well
because of the formidable amount of
training data
how much data was used exactly we don't
know
but it must have been the whole internet
like
open ai also did with gpt 3 and things
that were not
possible with academic size data sets
have now
become feasible with a model that has
seen it
all this does not make the dull e
results less impressive
but the creativity that we see with doll
e has something to do with the variance
of the data it has seen
take this example where they visualize
perspective and three dimensionality
yes perspective and 3d looks very good
in general
but impressive form is coffee bean is
how the model knows to make a capybara
from
voxers it becomes clear that something
like this
is possible only because of all the
minecraft and other pixel art images
that the model had access to
we would never expect from a style gun
to make something sensible out of the
word voxel if it has never seen the
voxelized images before in the gaming or
art area
of the internet and has been limited to
a benchmark
data set of celebrity faces only
with enormous data and variance comes
great power
let's look at more showing off of this
power
openai invested a lot of time into this
blog post
did you ever have trouble imagining a
cube made out of
porcupine well wait no more here it is
okay so a cube with the texture of
keyboard
okay one can also draw multiple boxes
and really tell the model how to render
these
wow this is awesome
oh these plates are so cute
and so were you making a youtube video
but did not
have exactly that emoji you were
imagining
wait no more dal e is here to paint it
for you
and this is very interesting from a
multi-modal perspective that
one description can have so many
possible outcomes
while this is amazing i can play with it
the whole day
remember the image completion example
well one can even change the pose of
this bust
okay here are some failure cases
interesting to see
especially because we don't know if open
ai was cherry-picking in this blog post
we don't know because we don't have
access to the model
and of course the applications are
limitless do you want to design a new
t-shirt
just tell daley how to draw it and then
you have many versions of
said t-shirt on a mannequin because you
introduce
the mannequin head with an image prompt
and
well you have here your designed
fashion this has huge industrial
applications
and yes the combination of unrelated
concepts
wow i mean this is is this art one could
ask
it made a snail into a harp or you know
it made a heart made of snail
and this can be creativity one might
think
so it is exactly how they put it it is a
3d
rendering engine via natural language
you just say what you want
daley to paint and it paints it and you
can expect the model to
fill in the blanks which means that you
underspecified
your rendering instructions and the
model comes up with
something and we cannot tell for sure
but it might
just be that this something that it
fills in the blanks with is just the
most probable
example that it has seen in the training
set
which already opens the pandora box
of bias in the blog they promise to
investigate
the societal impacts and check for
biases hopefully
sooner than later until then or
until they release the model one can
just scroll through this
blog indefinitely but we really cannot
deny it
these are impressive results from dal-e
bridging the gap between
vision and language stepping into the
multi-modal realm
multi-modality is my dearest topic in
machine learning
miss coffee bean what's your favorite
topic
oh okay so you don't want to tell us
fine
but back to dal e however excited i
might be about this
i have to say i am also a little
frustrated about all this
because throwing the whole data of the
internet that the problem solves
the problem rather than clever tricks
and gimmicks presented so far in the
multi-modality literature
you know by ordinary mortals unlike open
ai
especially as a phd student one has to
take these results you know
a little diluted to still feel a little
relevant
you know in this whole systems but you
know
everything is not done yet future
research will tell us about the real
capabilities and
problems that these models bring with
them
also i really hope that they will keep
their promise and
investigate societal impacts and biases
until then i will keep scrolling this
blog in all
miss coffee bean will get back to making
another video and
you know what about you let us know in
the comments what you will do
and hope to see you in the next video
okay bye
you